hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from the fifth edition of
the shah jack masters you guys suggested
uh
this one uh as it's a really wild
attacking game with the
well with the black pieces in the
sicilian really really uh sharp lines
everywhere salis salem versus no rebecca
abdusatorov uh you guys will enjoy this
one and especially if you play the
sicilian uh you will
you will feel really happy about this
one uh so let's dive straight into it uh
solid opens with e4 we have c5 the
sicilian is on the board knight to f6 uh
we've uh e6 uh sorry knight to f3 e6 d4
c captures knight captures and now
knight to c6 so the standard time on
variation where knight to c3 is pretty
much uh you know
you just play this you don't even think
about it but here we have knight to b5
this is the zen variation and it's not
extremely rare it's the second most
popular move after knight to c3 but it's
uh very very interesting and you don't
see it very often uh in in top level
chess so here we have d6 uh of course
you can see that the knight and queen
are going for that d6 square so if you
don't know this line and you you're
afraid of knight to d6 check uh makes
sense to play uh pawn to d6 but also
pawn to d6 is the strongest move so even
if you don't know the line you will play
d6 and if you know the line very well
you will also play d6 uh but just to
give you an example for example if
knight to f6 which is a very nice
counter-attacking idea you just go after
the pawn on e4 uh you don't really care
about this if this we're just going to
capture it but there's the very
interesting bishop f4 not just attacking
that c7 square so now we chase the
bishop with e5 bishop g5 and now bishop
c5 just going full counter attack knight
to c3 and now only now pawn to d6 here
we're going to play bishop captures on
f6 queen captures and now knights the c7
check but we don't care about this
because we're not losing the rook we are
threatening checkmate on f2 so first the
white has to deal with this let's say f3
and now we play rook to b8 okay now the
our rook is safe of course you cannot
capture the knight if you capture the
knight then you blunder your queen
knight the d5 check so it's just a
really really awesome line let's say
rook to b8 and now
white just continues developing queen d2
and uh it's a game so you know just in
case you were wondering if you can play
something else but d6
is the engine's absolute top
recommendation so everyone plays this so
now c4 yeah it is uh
often when playing against the sicilian
if your opponent still hasn't played
knight to f6 for some reason you have
time to grab more space in the center
with c4 usually you don't have time for
this because there will be a knight on
f6 and will be attacking this e4 pawn
but here as abdusatrov allows it pawn to
c4 knight to f6 now attacking the pawn
and now knight 1 to c3 a6 attacking the
knight knight to a3 and now bishop to e7
we have bishop to e2 and both players
castle so castles castles and now pawn
to b6 preparing to fiance to the bishop
and also get the rook into the game and
now you can see that both players have
two knights developed in the bishop
however now asylum's a knight on a3
isn't all that impressive at some point
it's going to come to c2 and then maybe
to e3 maybe to g4 f5 d5 all depends on
how the position opens up so here bishop
to e3 bishop to b7 and queen to b3 now
putting pressure on that b6 pawn uh
knights the d7 defending the pawn and
now rook f2d1 preparing the other rook
to come to c1 we have knight to c5 now
again you don't have an attack on the b6
pawn anymore and the knight here is
excellently placed attacking the queen
so queen back to c2 and now bishop to f6
just improving um
the position of the pieces a little by
little now you could bring the rook to
c1 as it was planned but first we have
f3 defending the e4 pawn once more and
now bishop to e5 now the queen can come
into the game as well uh but there is uh
no danger of this uh for the moment
first bishop to f1 now our queen gets
access to the second uh second rank and
also uh if queen to h4 we're just gonna
play g3 so that's not really an option
we have f5 here attacking the central e4
square and now the position has been
reached before however in all the games
that where the position was reached e
captures and if uh 5 was played which is
not that impressive it's actually very
very bad for white however here f4 is a
new move uh it was never played before
and it's actually the top move
recommended by the engine so now as a
move 17 we have a completely new game
and it's uh well it it's it's a a very
very precise way to play the new game so
here uh what do you do your bishop is
attacked and now comes bishop captures
on c3 if you don't capture on c3 if you
move the bishop then e5 is very strong
as the deep on his pin so you don't want
to allow this so after f4 bishop
captures on c3 and now uh you should
probably capture the knight on c5 the
problem is if you capture the knight on
c5 uh then black can just move the
bishop back and if you move your bishop
back and then we'll capture on e4 and
we've just won a pawn if you capture
here then you no longer guard the the
the b two point we're going to play
bishop captures on b2 and this will be
of course better for black so asylum
doesn't like this he plays queen
captures on c3 instead gives up the e4
pawn knight captures on e4 and now queen
b3 again ready to capture on b6 but now
rook to b8 and this is now where the
game
becomes really really exciting you can
see that white is down a pawn and white
has a chance to win back the pawn and it
will uh it will fall with tempo bishop
captures and b6 attacks the queen but is
there any danger of this um
rook queen relationship on the b file
there's still the bishop in between so
uh it should be safe for you to capture
it but um you know
interest often what you think isn't
what's actually happening so here safest
for white is just to bring this knight
back into the game like we mentioned
knight to b1 to c3 uh would be the
safest way to play this but uh sally
accepts the challenge he plays bishop
captures on b6 attacks the queen and now
queen to h4 okay black not threatening
so much here you have to be careful that
f2 square might be a problem but for the
moment your bishop is um
is defending that square so here queen
to e3 we want to get our queen away from
the rook here plus we're guarding our
bishop from here and the f2 square from
here so here e5
opening up the position and you have to
be very careful if you capture then f4
might come and then well
you you will have problems here so here
g3 attacking the queen queen to f6 and
now bishop to g2 preparing to counter
this bishop uh e captures on f4 and now
g captures on f4 if queen captures on f4
then the problem is you are no longer
defending your bishop and now just queen
captures on b2 comes with an attack on
the knight and on the bishop so here
unfortunately sullivan has to capture
with the g pawn open up his king a
little bit and now comes queen
g6 this is much stronger than capturing
on b2 now here you don't really gain
anything because the queen guards the
bishop and the knight just the bishop to
c7 and now it's uh well now white is no
longer in in any trouble so instead
queen to g6 putting a whole lot of
pressure on that g2 square and now
knight to c2 finally the knight starts
uh to come back into the game but now
comes knight to e5 a beautiful beautiful
sacrifice that
can't really be captured the problem is
if you capture here then you allow f4
and there's no way uh the the rook
defends the pawn the queen and bishop
now defend the knight you have to move
the queen and it doesn't really matter
where you move the queen let's say queen
h3 you want to keep an eye on the bishop
on g to f3 and the entire uh white's
position just crumbles so after e 95 we
have queen back to e2 and now knight to
g4 putting now pressure on the h2 pawn
so you have to be very very careful here
rook to d3 and now knight e to f6
opening up the uh e file for for for the
black rooks uh bishop back to d4 and now
we have rook f38 attacking the queen
here and now you don't have a good
square for the queen you kind of want
your queen to defend the the bishop on
g2 and you can do this via the
d2 square or via the f1 square if you
try queen to d2 we can capture on h2
immediately so we're going to show this
even though it wasn't played in the game
let's say king captures queen to h5 with
check now white can block with rook to
h3 seems like white defended everything
it's perfectly fine uh the problem is
this rook the e2 move uh wins the game
for black and obviously
saw this so he didn't go into this line
now the problem is uh how do you defend
if you move the queen just through a
capture sun
on g2 if you capture the black queen we
just capture here and now you cannot
defend the bishop here plus your rook is
hanging so best best you you can play is
just bishop captures on f6 but now rook
captures in g2 king h3 and now rook
captures on c2 uh we're gonna we we have
to defend the bishop i remove the bishop
or threatened to pick up the pawn so
let's say g6 and now rook to e1
preventing rook to e8 and it seems like
white survived you're down only one pawn
the problem is this bishop and black's
rooks will become too active and white
doesn't really have a good way of
activating the pieces let's take f7
attacks the bishop bishop has to move
somewhere now we can even play rook to
c8 attack the pawn
and you can't really defend you can play
b3 because the bishop hangs you have to
play something let's say bishop b4 now
we collect another pawn and well
a white's position just falls apart uh
so here after rook after e8 queen to f1
was played as that line
isn't isn't very good but now comes
knight to h5
and now uh it seems like uh it seems
like you have time to defend you can
bring your rooks into the game you can
uh you know uh improve your your
position so rook to d2 is played but now
comes rook to e4 we're gonna do this one
in slow motion there we go rook to e4
beautiful beautiful move uh now saying
that white has no way of defending the
f4 pawn and rook captures on f4 is
coming and uh well okay you could
capture with uh the bishop on e4 but
then you i mean you open up your king to
all sorts of nasty discoveries uh after
bishop captures we first would need to
capture with the bishop and now all of
the squares are taken you can't uh move
the king anywhere you could play a rook
to g2 which seems like okay you give
back some material just to survive but
the problem is it doesn't work not by a
long shot bishop captures queen captures
not just knight captures on f4 and you
don't have a good square with the queen
to avoid nasty discoveries if queen to
g3 we can just play knight to d to uh uh
check with this beautiful royal fork so
here white would just resign or if queen
to h1 that's even worse now we're gonna
play knight the e3 with check and after
king to f2 just knight captures on c2 uh
we are up uh too much material there's
there's no way for for white to play
this and of course you will soon get
checkmated so instead after rookie four
rook to e1 was played uh challenging
that rook on e4 uh but now we just
capture on f4 as that was our plan all
along so rook captures on f4 attacking
the queen queen to d3 and now comes a
beautiful finisher knight to f2 and he
was in this position on move 32 that
sally salim resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
beautiful beautiful uh game by both of
them but no derby takes takes the win
and they finished the tournament uh on
seven out of nine both of them
with sort of a shared first place uh but
not rebecca wins the tournament as he
won their wonder encounter uh here you
resign as you are uh getting checkmated
obviously and you have to prevent this
somehow if you block with the queen
queen to f1 then you just allow all
sorts of nasty discoveries again knight
h3 check the bishop cannot move you also
uh now expose the queen here king h1
rook captures and that's it i mean
you're down a queen you have no
compensation here and if you try
something else let's say you captured
the knight now you are defending against
checkmate we're still going to play rook
captures on f2 and after king captures
not just a mate into queen captures and
g2 check king of king e3 and of course
pawn to f4 will be checkmated there's no
uh square for the for the king to go to
the bishop covers all of these squares
the queen also covers all of these
squares so there's just nothing uh to be
done here and the knight of course
controls uh defends the pawn
so uh like i said beautiful game of both
of them but no rebecca really really
takes the win so for those of you who
enjoy playing the sicilian uh i think
you will be very much very much inspired
and you know just go straight online and
you know crush your opponents as you
usually do uh but yeah uh here you see
just uh uh i mean it's a it's a really
fun line and not going for the standard
knight to see three knight to b5 trying
to mix it up a little bit uh but as
you've seen black defended well and
that's why uh in for example in absolute
top competitions like the like maybe the
world church championship or the
candidates tournament you will you will
pretty much only see the absolute top
top lines and not maybe the
maybe the second move recommended by the
engine simply because it's a little bit
easier easier to defend maybe but here
it was attempted and a very nice victory
for abdusatorov uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh play
the sicilian uh you know crush your
opponents with black that's that's the
good stuff uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to jay greenblatt
and i would like to thank the first
elden lord nagarjuna ponogoti congrats
harry three grass and andre theron for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day